sie sehen es hinter mir hitze
trockenheit waldbrände meine damen und
herren in deutschland aber besonders
stimmen derzeit im süden europas so
viele ja auch im urlaub sind dramatische
bilder heute aus frankreich südlich von
bordeaux die französische regierung hat
um internationale hilfe gebeten weil sie
alleine nicht mehr klarkommt und
deutschland hilft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wort feuerhölle hier bekommt es ein
gesicht im südwesten frankreichs in der
nähe der weinstadt porto brennen seit
wochen die wälder bis mittwoch waren die
feuer noch weitestgehend unter kontrolle
doch starke winde entfachen das inferno
aufs neue seit dienstag sind schon über
6000 hektar wald zerstört mindestens
5800 menschen müssen ihre häuser
verlassen
die französische feuerwehr ist völlig
überfordert kämpft gegen einen feind der
übermächtig scheint das feuer überrascht
uns immer wieder aufs neue was ist als
nächstes macht kann ich ihnen nicht
sagen das volk bewegt sich ständig mal
verlangsamt es sich dann verschwindet es
nach norden oder nach süden dann kehrt
es wieder das bringt das an die grenzen
grenzen die das inferno setzt
[Musik]
im kampf gegen das übermächtige feuer
rückt jetzt auch verstärkung aus
deutschland
die internationale für den europäischen
einsatz gedachte spezialeinheit macht
sich in den frühen morgenstunden aus
bonn auf den weg nach frankreich der
verband besteht aus 20 einsatzfahrzeugen
und rund 70 einsatzkräfte mit dabei
schweres gerät tonnenweise denn es wird
benötigt also das szenario was dort in
südwestfrankreich uns erwartet scheint
sehr dynamisch zu sein hat sich in einer
nacht dort extrem schnell auf dem extrem
großen fläche erweitert die
wettervorhersagen für die nächsten tage
lassen auch noch nicht auf besserung
hoffen so dass wir davon ausgehen dass
unsere unterstützung dort dringend
benötigt wird die waldbrand einer die
jetzt abgerückt ist ist die einzige im
europäischen gemeinschaft verfahren
registrierte einheit dieser art die wir
letztes jahr erstmalig in griechenland
schon sehr erfolgreich im einsatz wir
konnten dort vor ort und auch unserem
einschätzung sehr gut helfen und die
griechische feuerwehr kräfte
unterstützen haben auf der anderen seite
aber auch sehr sehr viele wertvolle
erfahrungen für unsere arbeiten unsere
einsatzvorbereitung auch wieder mit nach
hause genommen
erfahrung die jetzt hier gebraucht wird
[Musik]
gemeinsam gegen die waldbrände die
naturkatastrophe in frankreich ist
längst kein nationales problem mehr
[Musik]
und deshalb fragen wir noch mal nach bei
professor dr johann goldammer er ist der
führende waldbrand forscher guten namen
der professor einen schönen genommen die
feier schienen ja unter kontrolle zu
sein flammen dann jetzt wieder auf für
die laien unter uns kann man
kontrollierte feuer nicht komplett
löschen und so ein neues entfernung
verhindern
na ja wir haben eine ganz
außergewöhnliche situation in frankreich
die besonders gefährlich wird wie schon
erwähnt durch die winde und erinnern wir
uns mal an die brände hier im
osterzgebirge in brandenburg in
nordsachsen da waren vor allen dingen
dann die situation schwierig wenn wir
diesen starken wind hatten und da ist es
häufig so dass die einsatzkräfte dann ja
praktisch an ihre grenzen stoßen und die
feuer so heftig brennen dass sie
manchmal gar nicht direkt sondern nur
indirekt bekämpft werden können und da
muss man auf der ganzen klaviatur
spielen unsere französische kollegen
können dass die sind ja mit etwa 10.000
mann im einsatz in frankreich die
verfahren beispielsweise auch gegen
feuer zu legen
löschflugzeuge und hubschrauber
einzusetzen die ist in frankreich
vorhanden ich fand es überraschend zu
hören von einem feuerwehrmann dort der
sagte wir wissen gar nicht mal taucht es
hier wieder auf mal brennt es da wieder
und wir haben keine ahnung und werden
immer wieder überrascht lässt sich das
nicht vorausberechnen sozusagen wie sich
das feuer weiter entwickelt
ja das geht schon denn diese neuen feuer
die neuen brandherde die entstehen sind
in der regel ausflug feuern und das
macht eben der wind der wind der eben
brennende teile aus einem waldbestand
weiterträgt und da kann die windrichtung
oft sehr schnell ändern das sehen wir
hier bei unseren übungen und
demonstrationen in deutschland wenn wir
solche gegenfeuer beispielsweise üben an
einem nachmittag wo sich die winde im
offenland sehr stark drehend innerhalb
von wenigen sekunden um 180 grad dann
muss man sehr starkes augenmerk darauf
legen und es ist hochgradig gefährlich
weil eben die einsatzkräfte auch vom
feuer eingeschlossen werden können nun
haben wir eine große hitzeperiode und es
steht zu befürchten dass das in der
zukunft auch noch schlimmer werden kann
was mit dorte all diese waldbrände für
die fauna und flora in europa
langfristig gesehen
ja wir müssen uns im zeichen der
klimakrise wirklich neu aufstellen im
blick auf das was bisher vertraute
forstwirtschaft waldwirtschaft war wenn
wir nur mal beim wald bleiben gewalt
wird sich verändern er muss sich oder er
muss von den menschen wir sprechen hier
über
kulturlandschaften und die wälder sind
ja überall auch in der region seeland in
frankreich sehr intensiv bewirtschaftet
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen bei
einem klima was uns mehr längere und
lang anhaltende und trockenperioden
bringt oder auch diese hitze wählen dann
wird es in zukunft so aussehen dass die
wälder doch mehr einen offenen charakter
bekommen nicht mehr so dichte
geschlossene welt da kann die
forstwirtschaft auch direkt eingreifen
und bestände schaffen die dann nicht so
überlastet sind einmal vom stehenden
bestand aber auch vom totholz im bestand
und wenn man das richtig und langfristig
an geht für die kommenden jahre und
jahrzehnte
dann kann es gelingen die welt sozusagen
feuer resilient aufzubauen dazu muss
aber investiert werden die pflanzliche
biomasse kann aber auch genutzt werden
als erneuerbare energie wir können
freunde einsetzen das sind tiere die
weltweite machen und den wald freihalten
von diesen gefährlichen beiden material
also auf der klaviatur kann man spielen
professor goldammer danke für ihre
erklärung
sehr gerne
[Musik]